les ministre de la Santé ont
chercher actuellement des
solutions. Anne-Louise Despatie.
- La carte et la Castonguette,
du nom de Claude Castonguay,
le père de l'assurance-maladie,
donnent aux Québécois un accès
gratuit aux soins de santé
à la fin des années 60.
Plus besoin de payer
la consultation du médecin.
Comme les tests en laboratoire
et l'imagerie sont couvertsà l'e
de patients vont directement
aux urgences. C'est un peu
l'avènement de la "médecine
de corridor".
- À 9 h 30, mon petit garçon,
il n'en pouvait plus.
On a été obligés de revenir.
Il n'a pas passé.
- Robert Bourassa a visité cette
salle d'urgence de la Cité d
la santé, à Laval. Il y a vu 57
patients dans les corridors.
- Mais il y a des engagements
qui ne sont pas négociables,
c'est d'avoir une médecine
civilisée au Québec.
- Détournements d'ambulances,
engorgement et files d'attente,
politique d'admission inefficace
et mauvaise répartition de lits,
ce sont là des problèmes vécus
depuis 10 ans dans les salles
d'urgence à Montréal et
à Québec.
- On cherche toujours le remède
à l'engorgement, une décennie
plus tard.
- Le gouvernement va développer
des hôpitaux de jour et
des unités de gériatrie.
THÉRÈSE LAVOIE-ROUX
Ministre de la Santé (1985-1989)
- Est-ce que c'est demain matin
que le médecin coordonnateur
à l'urgence et à l'admission
va être là? Je pense qu'il faut
quand même laisser aux mesures
le temps de se mettre en place.
- Mais les images de couloirs
encombrés de civières continuent
de faire les manchettes.
En 1990, le ministre de
la Santé veut y mettre fin.
MARC-YVAN CÔTÉ
Ministre de la Santé (1989-1994)
- Allez sur la place publique
avec vos urgences, vous allez
faire peur aux administrateurs,
puis à partir de ça, ils vont
vous donner de l'argent.
C'est fini, ca!
- Marc-Yvan Côté répond avec son
Groupe tactique d'intervention.
Ce groupe de médecins est vite
rebaptisé "La police des
urgences" et a pour mandat
d'insuffler de l'efficacité
dans le système.
PAULINE MAROIS
Critique de l'Opposition, PQ
- Il faut qu'on ait des
solutions qui vont faire
en sorte qu'on reconnaisse
la lourdeur des clientèles
puis la rémunération
du personnel.
- La situation s'améliore
un peu, mais l'attente dépasse
encore trop souvent les
48 heures pour ceux qui ont
besoin d'être hospitalisés.
La pression est forte
sur le personnel soignant.
JENNIE SKENE
présidente de la FIIQ
- Mais s'il n'y a plus de place
en haut, sur les étages,
le 48 heures dans le corridor,
est-ce qu'il doit se traduire
par le trottoir?
- Depuis l'hiver dernier,
ça n'arrête pas. L'urgence
accueille deux fois plus de
patients que sa capacité,
des personnes âgées, surtout.
- La ministre Pauline Marois
voudrait bien régler de façon
permanente les débordements
dans les urgences.
Son plan réussira-t-il?
- Les gouvernements changent.
Les promesses restent.
PHILIPPE COUILLARD
ministre de la Santé (2003-2008)
- Le CHUM Notre-Dame
particulièrement est
une urgence qui est extrêmement
problématique.
- Au tournant des années 2010,
le problème persiste.
- J'ai pas vu ça jamais encore,
là, 53 heures d'attente!
- Tout ce que je veux, c'est
un rayon X pour mon pied,
voir si c'est cassé ou pas.
- Pendant qu'on tente de soigner
plus de malades chroniques
à domicile, les urgences
continuent de déborder.
- Assez, c'est assez!
- Une patiente meurt
sur une civière de l'hôpital
Maisonneuve-Rosemont après
quatre jours d'attente.
YVES BOLDUC, ministre
de la Santé (2008-2012)
- En fin de semaine,
on va trouver 100 places
pour des patients en attente
d'hébergement.
- Depuis 2008, la ligne 811
a pour mission de limiter les
visites inutiles à l'urgence.
En 2014, l'ancien président
de la Fédération des médecins
spécialistes arrive avec
ses solution.
GAETAN BARRETTE
ministre de la Santé (2014-2018)
- Si on veut baisser cette
attente-là à l'urgence, il faut
faire sortir les patients qui
prennent des lits qu'ils ne
devraient pas.
- Le premier ministre Legault
a lui aussi été ministre
de la Santé. En 2002,
sous un gouvernement péquiste,
il instaure un bulletin
des urgences.
FRANCOIS LEGAULT
ministre de la Santé (2002-2003)
- Nous sommes toutes et tous
un peu prisonniers de ce préjugé
tenace qui veut que toutes
les urgences du Québec soient
problématiques.
- Après 50 ans et une pandémie,
la situation dans les urgences
a pris des proportions de crise,
provoquant l'implantation
de la  cellule de crise
du ministre Dubé.
Ici Anne-Louise Despatie,
Radio-Canada, Mon